Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble
and fully self-enlightened one so these past these two talks really are more theoretical side just so that we we can put our meditation into a sort of greater perspective really so yesterday we looked at it from the point of view of you know the psychology that the Buddha taught
Tonight, just to go a bit wider into what we understand by karma, so for many of us it will just be a bit of repetition, but it's worth just reflecting on these things over and over really.
Just as a warning, when Ananda had been with the Buddha for quite some time, he said to him, you know,
Bhagavan Lord I think I understand this dependence origination and the Buddha said oh no Ananda this stuff goes deep subtle so that blew him out so everything you hear from me you have to understand is not as deep as obviously somebody like the Buddha would go but at least it gives us some indication so karma is a very central
concept to the Buddha's teaching and of course it wasn't as though it wasn't known at the time there were many ideas about karma karma here means action more than karma with the R karma it's come into our languages as result you know like you deserve it it's your karma but technically karma means an act and what follows is known as viparka you see
So I might confuse you with these terms as I go on, so you have to leave notes for me.
First of all, sort of two general statements.
The first one is about the way the Buddha saw our experience and the way it was understood at those times.
The world and consciousness were one and the same thing.
We, over a period of two or three hundred years or whatever, have separated the world out and seen it as very objective.
And it's brought us the scientific revolution, it's brought us industrial revolution, technological revolution.
It's brought us a huge load of gifts.
But we, generally speaking, live under the delusion that what I see and feel really exists out there.
And that it really is.
out there and I'm actually experiencing it as a true object these days of course with our neurobiology and all that come to realize that in fact that's completely untrue and that we live in a world that we have concocted ourselves in our own little brains within our own bubble of consciousness and the magic of it is that it does produce this world outside
that doesn't mean to say the world outside doesn't exist and it exists if all human beings disappear from this planet they'd still be the planet I mean it's not as though it doesn't exist but it's not we cannot see it in itself that's all and what this what this means is that when you're reading the scriptures you see when you hear a sentence when you hear a questioner like how do you get to the end of the world you see we might think oh well he's talking about a flat planet because in those days
Most civilizations thought the earth was flat, and that was what he meant.
But generally speaking, it was always meaning, where do we get to the end of consciousness?
Where does the world end?
And in that phrase that I quoted last night, there is a consciousness which has nothing in it, it's not manifested,
without boundary and in all directions full of light, the questioner had asked, where do the four great elements come to an end?
By which he means, where does the world come to an end?
And the Buddha says, that's the wrong question.
You see, he said, that's a mistaken question.
The question should be, where do the four elements not find a footing?
Ah, see?
And then he comes out with this phrase,
in other words this consciousness where you know I keep saying this which we are close to when we are in the state of the observer is something which is beyond this phenomenal world so that's one thing the real point about karma is that the world we are living in is truly being created by us it depends on our eyes of course what we see in our ears
it a lot depends upon the culture we're in, the way we understand things yes that's all information coming in but what we actually experience is actually being created by us so if this room for instance nobody would deny it disappeared if we all left but all of us have a different experience of this room so there are as many rooms here by way of personal experience as there are people that's the point okay
Now what this means is, if I'm creating my world, if I'm truly creating my world, and it's a mess, then it must be me that's creating the mess.
I mean, it's just, if I'm suffering, nobody's causing it, it's me, I'm doing it somehow.
So then there is this investigation of, well, what am I doing to create this mess, you see?
And that's, of course, the process of vipassana, the process of insight.
so just putting that to the side for a minute because you know it'll come into what spiritual karma means as opposed to the more should we say traditional traditional meaning of karma in other words what how people have come to understand it is very very mechanical it's not like that at all so that's that's that side you see we are living in our own world and we're we're actually manufacturing it right
we are doing whatever we can with the stimulus which is coming in so remember you know if you're colorblind you see that you live in a different world to most of the people that's the end of that so the next thing is is to understand what the Buddha means by causality and it's known as the iddha pacchiatta which means the lord of this and that and to put it simply
because that happened this happens and because that didn't happen this doesn't happen and because this happens now this happens and because this doesn't happen now this doesn't happen now at first sight you'd think well that's a little bit this and that so the first one is the linear causality which most of us would understand very simply as because this happened in the past this happens now so for instance
at the end of the week when you look at your bank account and you've seen the wages go in then you know that's because you just worked this past week if you didn't it wouldn't go in you know one way or the other so there's a definite way of looking at what's happening now with its relationship to what's happened in the past I mean that's pretty straightforward it's sort of linear causality now the problem with that is logically speaking
where would creativity come in?
If everything is some repetition of the past or caused by the past.
It would suggest a very repetitive universe, you know, like a mechanical wheel.
And from a moral point of view, it would definitely suggest some form of fate or predestination.
Because how can you change anything if it's determined from the past action?
See?
And of course, sometimes you do get the feeling that
You know, things have happened to you as a fate.
How else, you see?
So having only that view of time, that view of the way things happen, puts us into a sort of strange place.
And it wouldn't make any sense to think about, you know, looking at our intentions and being able to change them and stuff like that because everything's, things would have happened anyway.
It's all because of something in the past.
So that's that linear causality.
The other one is because this happens now, this happens.
So this is much more immediate.
So here we have it, you see.
From a linear point of view, we've all arrived in this room.
But from an immediate causality point of view, the whole situation would be different if even one of us left.
It's taken all of us to create this course.
So if all of us hadn't been here, this course wouldn't be here now.
If you all suddenly decided this Bodhidharma is just a load of rubbish, and you all get up and left, the course will come to an end, you see.
That'll be the end of it.
So the fact that we're all here means that I can give forth.
that brings us into an immediate causality now the problem with that one is if everything is just immediate then presumably we're looking at a chaotic universe because there's no connection between anything I mean anything could happen anytime depending on what was happening at the present moment there wouldn't be any sense or some sort of connection or anything you see and
morally speaking that leads us to an amorality because you know what the hell you know you murder somebody and maybe get away with it maybe you don't and that's the way a lot of people might think you know you you rob a bank and you might get away and you might don't and that's because of present conditions so that leads us into a little bit of a little bit of an impossible situation from the Buddha's point of view if we think that
you know our actions have effect you know future effect if you live in a chaotic universe well you don't know what's going to happen you know there was a case now just listening to this news so this man crazy fellow unbelievable really married this poor woman and within a week or a year of their marriage he killed her
caused a crash, set the fire, set this car on fire, and claimed this massive amount of insurance, and got away with it.
And then he tried it again in New Zealand, he got copped.
And then they found him, he escaped, and they found him later, trying to get this poor woman to give him his will, give him all his money.
So, you know, you might think, well, if he'd have got away with that, we live in a chaotic universe.
It doesn't really matter, you know, there's no connection.
You can get away with things.
So that would lead us to, I think, to a position where morality wouldn't be so important.
There might be other reasons for being moral, but it doesn't work so well.
Now, the Buddha's position is that there are both of these laws.
There's both this causality coming from the past, and there is also this contingency, this immediate meeting
of these different lines of karma these different lines of actions and we can include in this all nature as we will in a minute so physically the physical universe and the plant life and the animal life and the human life are all converging all the time into little events which are a compendium of all these streams of actions coming from who knows where
and what this gives us is a very creative universe because first of all there's always some connection to the past there's for want of a better word a rationality to the process but also there's an unknowability because you don't know exactly what's going to meet so if you just look at say a natural disaster
this dreadful tsunami in Japan you see so that was happening from one law and these people were just getting on with ordinary living and suddenly this happened you see I mean that's always to think of it in a negative sense but also in a beautiful sense the weather suddenly becomes beautiful and everybody's out on the beach so you don't it's like there's things coming from the past but they're meeting in the present
and the effect of their meeting in the present is unknowable and in that sense we live always in that sense of uncertainty and you've only got to bring it down to the present we don't know the hour, the day, the time when we're going to drop dead that's it if we knew that, well we could run from it we could try and get around it somehow
so it's that unpredictability and yet this amazing creativity and of course when you take it into the human what you have is philosophy, art, technology that's all working on these same principles things are coming to us from the past people are meeting in the present minds are meeting and suddenly something is produced so that
You might say that's the basic template upon which the Buddha understood the world to be behaving.
Then there are these five laws of which karma is only one.
The first one is the law of heat, as it's translated, or energy, which we can very easily translate into physics and chemistry.
It's that level of matter, as they would talk about it in the
in the medieval ages mineral the mineral world as they would talk about it and of course that has its own laws full stop we just talked about you know the tsunami earthquakes you see so there are these different laws running alongside each other you see and every so often they produce something beautiful such as this planet and other times they they can be quite destructive but there is this law you see that the law
concerning the material world.
The next one is biju, bija, bija miyama, which means seed.
So here we're genetics, you see.
So the bodies that we have ended up with are the product of past generations.
And the actual original cell of our body
contains with it stuff that's come from the past material stuff that's come from the past when it develops it develops in the particular way of that original seed so again this isn't our personal karma I'm sure some of you will remember the English manager talking about
congenital diseases or being born.
Glenn Hoddle.
Yeah, dear old Glenn Hoddle, who I think, well, he says he was misinterpreted, who said that, says that if you're born, you know, with a deformity, that must be because you did something horrible in the past life.
And that disgusted so many people that he lost his job.
And of course, that wouldn't be the Buddha's point of view.
That wouldn't be the Buddha's point of view.
Although, in a sense, that's the way
you know traditional Buddhist would actually think about it because they they transpose this personal karma onto everything so even when the tsunami hits Sri Lanka you know that they might come up with some big some idea that they that they that was personal karma just on that note there's this tale in the in the
They're tales after the scriptures, you know, that are all added on to Buddhism.
But one of them is, I thought, rather telling, in which a ship is going along and it suddenly stops.
There's a wind up, but it suddenly stops, you see.
And so the captain wonders what to do and asks the monks, you see, there's a group of monks there, and asks them what...
You know, what do you think is happening?
So the monks went into deep and profound concentration and discovered actually it was his wife.
His wife in a past life seems to have drowned so many dogs.
So the only way the ship had moved was to chuck her overboard.
That's a clever way of getting rid of your wife, isn't it?
Anyway, they did so of course and the ship moved on.
So you get this dreadful sort of mechanical type of karma taught to kids and everything.
I mean, I once asked this elderly man who used to look after us at the monastery.
I was just generally interested.
We were talking about karma and this and that.
I just said to him, I said, why do you think Jesus Christ ended up on the cross, dying such a painful death?
you must have done something terrible in your past life you know like there just isn't the concept that you can suffer for compassion's sake or for love's sake it's just you know that was it really so this idea of our bodies being personal karma also doesn't work because it comes from a you know situations which are simply not under our control we just end up with this body
Of course, when we're in the body, when the mind and what we do to the body gets in there, well then that is part of our personal karma.
But the original structure and all that is there.
And that's how you get family diseases.
All mine, up until now, apart from one, die of strokes and heart stuff.
So I'm expecting to go any moment.
I'm coming to the age when I should fall off a cliff or something.
So that comes through the family and it may be, you know, that this is because some earlier generation was immoral in some way and has caused a weakness within the genetic structure.
So this lovely thing that, you know, you read in the Bible that the sins of the father will be on the generation for seven generations.
That's very interesting because there were some reports I read where
If your grandmother or grandfather was overweight, then it's probable that you will be.
And that's how quick the genetic structure can be changed and affected.
So if we care for our future generations, stay slim.
So there's that whole area of genetics and our bodies as physical, you know, as a physical thing.
which is not part of personal karma.
That's the important thing.
The next thing is citta.
So citta is your mind, so it's psychology.
And here, some writers stretch that out to include our society, because society is simply a conjoining of minds.
And what we're really talking about here is just the fundamental way the mind works.
So in other words, we have sense bases,
it brings in certain stimulus the brain-mind complex remember in Buddhism the mind and the brain are two different forms of energy there's not just the material brain there but just putting that aside there's this whole mentation process going on which is producing for us images, thoughts, etc.
and it's obvious that there's some sort of physical base to our thoughts and feelings
And that comes under mind itself.
I mean, some writers stretch that out into sociology and stuff like that.
It really depends on where you want to put the dividing line between that and karma.
Leaving karma aside just for a minute, the fifth one is, of course, the spiritual laws.
which is what we, you know, we learned from the Buddha.
Just the law of, well, the first one was cause and effect, but it's mainly to do with the Four Noble Truths and the Eightfold Path, and those instructions that take us out of the world of suffering.
So all that is also a separate area.
So if you keep those, if you sort of keep those divisions of the world separate, then you've got this business of karma, okay?
Now, we've said that we create our own worlds.
What was the next thing I said?
Create our own worlds.
Sorry?
Ah, no, no.
I was thinking of the actual law of causality.
So you've got
you've got the basic platforms you've got some the Lord of Causality and I am and the other one will do not go my will move on cell X2 through it all day sickness and death a senior moment the next one is and to do with understanding that's and
all our suffering and joys are an ethical problem the whole psychology in Buddhism is to do with ethics it's ethicized as it's put so for instance when somebody now for instance falls into depression we would see that rightly as maybe a medical problem a psychological dis-ease and I think that's perfectly skillful and perfectly alright but
from the Buddha's point of view the fundamental problem would be an ethical problem and this ethical problem isn't to do with a simple morality of right and wrong it's to do with relationship you see so if we go right back to the beginning all this massive suffering all the depressions and the anxieties and the worries and the guilt and all that all come about because of this wrong relationship with the world okay which substantiates itself
into a feeling of me the self the self isn't remember a thing it's a process right it's a bit like you know the word marriage so a marriage doesn't exist what exists is an ongoing painful relationship a trying relationship I'm giving away my experience there so again but
putting that aside so if you get away from the idea of self and you'll see some writers use the word selfing just to get that point across that it's a process of becoming somebody else all the time and just lost my train of thought there
where was I?
the problem with depression oh yeah thank you that's how I got it so we think of our mental problems as perhaps medical you see and we tend to psychologize things whereas from the Buddhist point of view it would be much more of an ethical problem now it doesn't particularly help knowing that if you suffer from depression I mean you know like you've got to treat it as a
as a mental dis-ease and we're getting rather good at that generally speaking in this society coming off drugs and teaching people how to use mindfulness and that sort of stuff and oh dear I've lost it again
I say ethics.
Karma.
Right, I'm with it.
I keep going off the point.
So, this karma is to do with our ethics, which is specifically to do with the way we're creating suffering.
Once we've grasped that, then we understand what this karma is.
It's nothing to do with the outside world.
It's to do with the inner world.
It's to do with the world I'm creating.
That's my real karma.
So, for instance...
I've just pointed out this guy who's committed these murders So he's going to end up in prison Now prison itself is not the suffering The suffering will be how he can bear with that situation And that situation is within his own mind So what happens to us from the outside is not our personal karma It's not the karma which leads to liberation
It's always what's happening inside.
See?
And that's what we're working with when we practice the Vipassana.
So when we sit here, you see, and somebody coughs just at the point when we're going to become fully liberated, you see, and then we get all angry and hot about it, then that's it.
We've created this world of heat and horror, you see.
Actually, all there was was a cough.
you know I mean it was just a sound but we've turned it into a disturbing noise you see so if you if we can grasp the idea that when the Buddha's talking about liberation and karma he's talking really about the world we're creating inside ourselves that's the real karma that's the real comeuppance so when you do something harmful the karmic result of that is not being put in jail
sure enough I mean that's obviously a result of it the karmic result is the feeling of guilt and shame and having and having to live in in a room for the rest of your life you see what I mean and how you deal with that so that's why where where spiritual karma is see that's that's the point of that's where the escape is from suffering it's within us see so
whatever happens to us from the outside, which may have some direct causality with us, I might have done something in the past which now produces some bad or some good results, heaven's sake, you know, like you buy a lottery ticket and you win a load of money, well that's pretty straightforward, that's good karma, you see, but that's not the karma of liberation, the karma of liberation is to do with
how we're now becoming attached to money, and how it's drawing us into a wrong relationship with the world, and which will eventually cause suffering.
So once we grasp the difference between what you might call an outer karma, which is all related, it's all contingent, and this inner karma, then you're much more concerned with the inner karma, because it's the inner karma which is actually producing the suffering, not the outer karma.
For instance, these days people are losing their work.
Well, to lose your job is bad enough.
To lose the finance that the job gives you is bad enough.
But then there comes loss of status.
What do I do now?
I've always defined myself as an engineer.
And now what am I?
I've always defined myself as a doctor.
What am I now?
You know, it's like, I always define myself as a bureaucrat.
Now, what am I now?
And it's that loss of identity which is going to create all the depressions and all that sort of stuff.
See?
And that's unnecessary.
That's the point.
It's all come about because of a wrong relationship with the work you're doing.
And tomorrow, you know, we'll go into what might be a right relationship so that that suffering doesn't arise.
I mean, the obvious word is service, to see your life as a service.
And if it's not wanted, well, that's okay.
You hate them for the rest of your life.
You've entered into it with a proper intention.
So that's the clarity we need when we're looking to the end of suffering.
We're creating our own suffering.
Nobody can cause us psychological suffering.
Can you grasp that?
Nobody can cause you that.
Physical suffering yes, nobody causes a psychological suffering that's all an internal process and if it were not so How could I become fully liberated from suffering unless I get rid of you lot?
I've got to get rid of all human beings and anything that disturbs me before I can become fully liberated It's the hot is the very fact that I'm creating my own suffering that means that I can uncreate it
and enter into this state, this relationship with the world, where there's no more psychological suffering.
See, that's the point.
Can I ask a question?
So, what you're saying here is that if I did something that is considered really bad, say, killing someone,
if I decided that actually I'm very happy about this, and I'm not going to be upset because I'm going to be in prison, and I'm going to deal with this in a good way, I know that's good, then actually, punishment doesn't need to exist.
Ah, I know.
You see, what happens is, I'm running out of time, really, but what happens is, of course, is that that attitude is a very surface attitude.
And it's not really connecting with the true heart of the person.
So what happens is that one becomes callous.
And then what happens is that that callousness goes out into the world and the world begins to mirror back your callousness.
Jung talks about this woman who turned up at his office and she had murdered her rival because she wanted to marry this man.
And she had come to a point in her life where she realized that all her children didn't want to know her.
She'd lost all her friends.
All these catastrophes happened.
And she made the connection that it all went back to this murder.
It all went back to this murder.
And he said in his book that he felt he'd suffered enough.
There was no point of him reporting this to the police.
She already understood what happens when you do something harmful.
in a sense even that doesn't make sense unless you see some continuity after death because you might get away with it and you might live a good life even if you do become calloused and all that you still might end up generally happy and that would seem to us a little unjust so here we have the doctrine of rebirth now the doctrine of rebirth just very quickly
it's not something you can scientifically prove.
I mean, how can you scientifically prove it?
Those people who remember their past lives, and there's a lovely clip that's going around on the websites about this young boy in America who remembers himself being killed during the Second World War against the Japanese.
He was in an airplane, and he remembers it quite distinctly
And the Japanese director is very interested in this and takes him out to where his plane went down.
And the interesting thing is he remembers his sisters and he says things about his sisters who are still alive in America.
He remembers all about them.
And he knows exactly where the plane went down.
And they even found somebody who was on the ship who remembered him and who remembered where the plane went down.
And this is all done by a little boy of about 11, 9, 10, 11, you see.
And of course he's got this creed that we shouldn't go to war.
So there are these, you know, and you get stories like that plenty in the East.
I think probably in the West we still suppress these things a little bit.
But if we understand that there is this consciousness, there is this Buddha nature, okay, and it's
it finds itself in a material world it finds itself in this physical world forms a relationship to this physical world where it thinks that this world is me okay and in so doing it forms an unethical relationship which creates acquisitiveness greed thieving and all that and aversion fear and all the rest of it all right and
when it leaves, upon death you see we can see it wanting to seek a similar world elsewhere it's seeking always rebirth even outside in the mental body it's still seeking I don't know, I mean we call them ghosts but basically they are these beings
that have found rebirth exactly around the places where they died.
I can tell you a wonderful story about a Portuguese who dared to attack me, but I won't go into that tonight.
This weekend, I'm like, I'm getting time.
I've got this forever, except when I lose my thread of thought.
So, I'm almost doing it now.
So...
yeah you see i've lost it see every time every time i go so that's right so uh this this consciousness is is always seeking you see where its happiness is and that's why it's drawn back into another life form constantly into another life form in the verse that we chant
in the morning of the Buddha's birth, he's been born from life to life to life, but he's found the house builder.
See?
He's found this mechanism that keeps creating the house, this body, this mind, you see?
And he said he's broken the rafters, smashed the poles, all very terrible stuff.
And he said, I have now achieved the chittam asankhatam, which means the unconditioned consciousness.
and all my defilements are destroyed and that's the point that the whole thing about rebirth without trying to work out its detail in hell realms and the whole cosmology of it is that process whereby this chittan, this consciousness is constantly seeking happiness and it's making this mistake so that's why it keeps being reborn
And so when it achieves its liberation from that delusion, you see, there's no knowing.
We don't know what happens to that consciousness.
Later tradition says the Buddha reappears in a blissful body and so on.
But generally speaking, the Buddha was silent, you see, because it was beyond descriptions, beyond words.
That's all.
So that's a lot tonight, actually.
Anyway, there's good books on this, so you don't have to...
Yes?
No, no, what you come back with, well, I can give you a few stories, but what you come back with is attitude.
And this attitude manifests within a given society as patterns of behaviour.
Yeah.
So if you come back with greed, you're going to find yourself in a greedy situation, because you're manufacturing the greedy situation.
If you come back with hatred, you find yourself in it.
If you come back with love, hey.
Well, we can go into that at the weekend, but that has a strong effect, just like when you go to sleep.
If you go to sleep with some big anxiety on your mind, what do you wake up with?
You see?
So,
now that's what I always also point out if you want to understand rebirth see what's happening now because it's happening right now we're rebirthing right now from moment to moment see not the same not different not the same not different see the connections there but there's something different and that's where the creativity comes in see sorry
Well, yes, you could put it that way.
The Buddha would point out that what drives us to seek the end of suffering is suffering.
Very simple.
If we didn't suffer, we wouldn't bother about it.
Ah, well, can we leave that for the weekend?
Because that's another question here.
That's a question here.
Very good.
i can only hope my words have been of some assistance may you by your careful investigation of the mind and the world we live in attain that peace sooner rather than later